[Musique]
je
bonjour cette année le challenge des
créateurs confronté jeunes entrepreneurs
à travers des thématiques de belles
rencontres partout dans l'île et ça
commence maintenant par le prix de
l'insertion
[Musique]
ancien sont que moi et représente un
coût le parc créole dans l'avenir de la
ville
[Musique]
challenge des créateurs japon gagné ses
six mille euros déjà et puis pour
pouvoir faire à l'agora
[Musique]
alors stéphane cette entreprise comment
ça s'est passé ben l'entreprise
quand même bébé s'appelle le carré d'as
le snack-bar carré d'as mais mène tout
le monde à venir voire même à la
jeunesse a aussi les anciens aussi via
la même arme à l'école dans le collège
et l'école primaire n'allait pas aussi
des lèvres que les très content - il
veut mettre en avant les eaux surtout
parce qu'ils m'ont beaucoup beaucoup
d'activités il manque une cohésion
sociale tout domoun un peu dispersés
dans notre mentalité comme dit créole
saissac un pressoir et certains points
ce soir
les possibles tout le monde nous incite
à nous nous les capable donc nous fait
pas peur tout pourquoi stéphane donc qui
était au pardon de l'emploi mais que ça
dure et ça a même été demandeur d'emploi
m'avait fini l'assedic ben grosse galère
pour trouver un emploi quoi d'un espace
vert et mara chamboule tout m'a dit eh
non il faut me crée il faut me créé
parce qu'il n'a plus rien et en créant
peut-être qu'il va emmène moon avec
moins dans la création envisage de
mettre un petit coin détente famille et
aussi par rapport que mais les
finalistes elle a déjà investi dans la
ba a vécu
moi j'ai bien aimé le parcours de ceux
de stéphane j'ai bien aimé une situation
difficile en terme d'emploi en terme de
formation une création d'entreprise
plutôt réussi et puis en plus un lien
social j'ai bien aimé cet aspect des
choses et en même temps c'est quelqu'un
qui préparent l'avenir pour pouvoir
diversifier son activité avec des
grillades et donc augmenter son chiffre
d'affaires
[Musique]
bonjour quand allez-vous bien alors ce
need a raconté nous c'est quoi votre
activité que faites vous qu'êtes vous je
suis artisan déjà au et artisans dans
café pour faire le café
j'exhorte le café j'ai créé mon activité
de bar ambulant de café bar ambulant
plus exactement ça fait environ deux ans
et le programme d'aujourd'hui heures
c'est quoi alors aujourd'hui on va aller
au marché des producteurs au théâtre de
saint-gilles où je vais vendre des
boissons
[Musique]
raconte nous ton parcours en matière je
dirais social qu'est ce qui a fait que
tu aujourd'hui chez entreprise
auparavant tu fais qu'un statut avant
j'étais presque c'est mickaël enfin j'ai
été responsable ensemble d'appel j'ai
exercé pendant dix ans en région
parisienne puis je suis revenu à la
réunion et voilà j'avais vraiment besoin
de mettre toute mon énergie
parce que c'est un nouveau concept c'est
pas non plus un concept qui a été vécu
par les autres on n'a qu'une vie quoi je
pense que si on a vraiment des bonnes
idées il y aura toujours les films
disponibles
ce sens la force de volonté on n'arrive
à rien et je pense que faut vraiment le
vouloir
jamais lâché prise et croire en son
projet original
le concept la leçon concept visuel et
technique
joli projet vente de café en ambulants
pour pouvoir promouvoir savane la
réunion en matière de café mais pas
seulement et donc volonté effectivement
de pouvoir s'en sortir pour un epr et sa
famille
[Musique]
c'est l'heure de la grande finale dans
l'hémicycle du département qui sera le
lauréat 2016 de la catégorie insertion
[Musique]
ils sont juste là les 12 finalistes
mais évidemment il a fallu les
départager ça s'est passé il ya quelques
jours avec les membres du réseau point
chance mais ça a été très compliqué
parce qu'en réalité tous ces
participants et symbolise la diversité
réunionnaise
et puis on a aussi essayé de primes et
l'originalité des projets parce que ça
semble intéressant de photographie à un
instant donné
cette réunion qui montre l'exemple bref
l'excellence réunionnaise de magnifiques
projets ils sont là derrière nous
stéphanie la face l'entreprise de carré
d'as sony tati roumat les entreprises le
barista run tir au tout tout qu on peut
encore les applaudir c'est magnifique ce
qu'ils ont fait le lauréat pour le prix
de l'insertion est madame sony tas si
vous mallet pour l'applaudir bravo bravo
la plaisir bravo vraiment félicitations
félicitations la grande réussite
on se bat tous les jours pour ça ou
toujours on se relâche pas c'est pas
facile d'être au four et au moulin dans
une entreprise qu'est ce que ça
représente ce prix-là gagner avec tout
ce que ça représente au quotidien comme
engagement m'a déjà ge la dédicace à mon
fils c'est important et c'est une vraie
continuité pour moi c'est un nouveau
souffle
j'en avais vraiment besoin et
aujourd'hui je pense que vraiment cette
histoire de laboratoire va voir le jour
et c'était une vraie extension et j'ai
un plan très nettement ma marque
c'est une histoire folle qui commença à
prendre forme et je vais rien lâcher ça
c'est clair
magnifique bravo félicitations je
voulais à ce prix
les espérons vous avez compris l'esprit
c'est à vous tous et bonne soirée et à
bientôt
[Musique]
je